there is some good news there is some
good news
in politics it's not all doom and gloom
it's not all bad hope springs eternal in
the human breast and there is on a
completely separate issue
some really great news one of the the
biggest challenges in america today is
that we are a
republic at least we're supposed to be
i mean self-government that means that
we govern ourselves by persuading one
another by debating by speaking to one
another and and we do that in the public
square now we no longer really have
physical public squares
we have digital public squares because
we live in the internet age so that
means that when big tech platforms which
control the entire flow of internet
entire flow of information around the
internet when they shut people out when
they censor certain topics when they
censor certain points of view when they
ban for instance the duly elected
sitting president of the united states
that
is is a major threat to our democracy to
our republic to the whole form of
government
well
someone is doing something about that
right now elon musk
one of the most delightfully eccentric
billionaires in the world
has had enough he sent out a twitter
poll the other day
he said free speech is essential to a
functioning democracy do you believe
twitter rigorously adheres to this
principle yes or no and he said be
careful how you answer
the consequences of this poll will be
important please vote carefully so the
majority of people believed that twitter
is not protecting free speech they
believe that free speech is very
important to democracy and so elon musk
has bought 9.2 percent of twitter he's
now the largest
stakeholder in twitter
and he intends to turn that company
around elon musk
now owns 9.2 percent of twitter
to put that in perspective
jack dorsey the founder and former ceo
of twitter owns 2.25
so so
elon musk owns almost four times
the the amount of twitter that jack
dorsey owns
as a result of this purchase twitter
shares surged
26 in pre-market trading
uh the the stake that elon has is about
2.89 billion
dollars
and what does this actually mean does
this mean that elon musk is going to
make a lot of money on twitter
i don't know maybe it will maybe it
won't he's a smart investor so i suppose
he'll probably make money but i suspect
this isn't primarily about money this is
about elon musk going in and throwing
his weight around and saying we are not
going to let free speech die in america
this is so beautiful and the context
here why is this happening right now the
the twitter annual meeting is may 25th
so when you own
when you own over nine percent of a
company like twitter
you can force the company to do certain
things
half of me wonders if the reason that
elon musk bought all this twitter stock
is is just to get the babylon b's
account back
because the babylon b which elon has
appeared on before made some joke about
transgenderism and they were banned and
they said you you can get your account
back if you delete the joke the babylon
b duggan said we're not going to delete
the joke and then in comes eli
and and you know it's real you know that
twitter is freaking out right now
because the ceo of twitter prague
agrawal
just sent out a big announcement he said
we're so excited to have elon musk on
board
he's on the board of directors now and
we couldn't be happier please don't fire
me elon please and then elon responds he
says yes i we can't wait to make some
changes over at twitter
it's just
it's just delicious and the the best
part about it
is something that has that has bugged me
and i know it bugs a lot of other people
in the conservative movement which is
that
conservatives are pretty good at talking
and pretty good at writing and even
pretty good at raising money in
non-profit organizations
but we're we're less good at doing stuff
out in the actual marketplace out in the
actual political system
this is what jeremy talked about when he
launched the razer company jeremy came
out and he said conservatives are really
good at whining and raising money and
then losing and then whining some more
and then raising some more money and
having a whole apparatus of non-profits
that doesn't really do very much
conservatives are good at that but if we
really believe that our ideas
are winners that they're vibrant that
they have strength we ought to throw
them right into the marketplace we ought
to actually try them out we ought to
throw our weight around we ought to we
ought to do more than just write long
journal articles i love journal articles
i read them i'm all about that scholarly
academic life it's great but we have to
do stuff in the real world too and so
elon rather than writing a ten thousand
word essay about the importance of free
speech he just threw two billion dollars
around and now he's gonna do it
and we can we can debate the philosophy
of that a little bit later we can debate
the nuances of that a little bit but
he's going to do it he's going to
protect free speech for now i strongly
suspect that's great stuff just do it
learn from nike take that nike rule
conservatives just do it and we'll
figure it out you want to make sure
things are just and moral and right and
prudent but let's do some stuff
and we'll let the chips fall a little
later we can do both
right now go to
knowles goodranchers.com price of beef
is skyrocketing it's only going to get
worse
over the summer right now you can lock
in your price for beef with good
ranchers once you subscribe your price
never goes up making good ranchers the
best way to inflation-proof your meals
eighty-five percent of the grass-fed
beef you get in stores and online
it's imported from overseas even when it
says product of usa usually that is bs
usually it's just minimally processed
here but it's cheap cheap beef from
overseas
you can shop good ranchers for all your
beef chicken and seafood needs they only
sell 100 american meat from local farms
and ranches i eat good ranchers at this
point probably two to three times a week
i love it so much when i was a kid steak
was a really rare kind of special
occasion experience well good ranchers
the price is so low and you can lock in
right now to make an inflation proof
you can you can make steak a regular
part of your family's
dining experience right now get your 30
discount on prime steaks and better than
organic chicken today go to
goodranchers.com
knowles k-w-l-e-s good ranchers takes
the guesswork out of the grocery store
sends you top quality 100 american meat
to your door use code knowles k-w-l-e-s
get 30 in savings goodranchers.com
knowles
i'm glad you like that clip if you want
to get more episodes more clips more
interviews
subscribe ring that bell also head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast subscribe to the michael knowles
show leave a 5 star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you